dans nos vies.
Jacques Bissonnet.
est envoyé sur un téléphone
portabmamamamarque Vodafone,
en décembre 1992, par
un ingénieur de l'entreprise :
Le premier tetetetetetetetetetr
en 1994 : un combiné sur
son chargeur appelé Simon
de IBM. C'est ce téléphone
la porte à cette nouvelle
façon deninininiquer.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les SMS pour "Short Message
Service" ou texto, comme
on
Et à partir de 1997, eh bien,
les grands fabriquants de
téléphones mobiles à travers
le monde développent une
Le phénomène prend
de l'ampleur, si bien qu'on
assiste dans les années 2000 à
mondial, les soirs de Nouvel Ant
moins cher d'envoyer un message
que d'effectuer un app
téléphonique.
Sur ce tout petit écran,
jouer à des jeux vidéo.
Viennent aussi les premiers
téléphones permettant
Et en 1999, eh bien,amamamamamx
BlackBerry canadien,
conçu par Research In Motion.
Cet appareil est devenu le choix
entre autres en raison
deerererererer et de
sa simplicité d'utilisation.
Mais c'est en 2007 qu'arrive
un événemele domaine des commun;
c'est la véritable folie :
lancement du premier iPhone
d'Apple à New York.
pour s'en procurer un.
(en anglais)
Ce téléphone est maintenant
devenu un petit ordinateur
de téléphone portable que
les médias sociaux ont pris
une telle ampleur.
- Mais revenons sur
le premier mes
envoyé il y a 30 ans.
Cet objet numérique dontçaçaçaçe
a été vendu aux enchères
en banlieue de Paris
l'an dernier pour la somme
un "Joyeux Noël" virtuel
e e e e e e e avec
les anciens voeux écrits,
les fameuses carte
livrées au rythme du postier.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, Montréa